[Music]
at the critics choice awards last
weekend director jane campion won for
directing power of the dog and during
her acceptance speech she said this
about venus and serena williams who were
also there serena and venus you are such
marvels
however you do not play against the guys
like i have to
champion has since apologized but i
think it's a shame that during what
should have been a happy moment she
decided to take a detour to try to dunk
on venus and serena now that happens a
lot for some reason white people love to
minimize what black people have been
through and compare it to their own
struggles oh no
i'm really sorry about that
jane campion what are you doing here
i just want to apologize again for my
speech it was wrong for me to diminish
the accomplishments of venus and serena
even if they don't have to play against
the boys like i do and i have to do it
in heels dude nuh-uh you're doing it
again
doing what again being a good ally no
the opposite comparing what you've gone
through to what black people have gone
through oh
sorry being an ally sure has had
i bet it's harder than being a black
lady with a late night show you're doing
it again
i did sorry what i meant to say is i bet
it's harder than being a black lady
that's worse
it was i do apologize to both you and
the black people in the audience
to have to leave your homes and face
racism in the real world just to come
here and have some white lady muck it up
well
that's almost as hard as being the white
lady mucking it all up
now this time i heard it sorry
i'm growing and learning and that's hard
almost as hard as what nelson mandela no
as hard as what rosa parks no
as hard as what martin no
not that martin martin luther king
okay that last one's on me they're all
on you dude okay let me reset
in action i'd like to issue a sincere
apology i am deeply sorry to have done
this on your program it must be
difficult to have someone interrupt your
show only to undercut the struggles and
accomplishments of black people in
america
almost as difficult as today stop
talking right there i don't think i can
being a black lady whose show gets
interrupted is probably as hard as you
do not have to do this it's probably as
hard as please make it stop i stop but
don't worry no it's probably as hot as
being me
champion everyone get out of here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you